It was a Tuesday after an ugly win
And I was flying higher than
Coach Foerster before an OL meeting
That's when he walked in
Fresh off his first win. He was 6'5" with a bolo tie
And a face that was downright
punchable
I want to report missing persons
Who's missin'?
The Los Angeles football fans
Damn, where were all those L.A. Chargers fans?
Kidnapped?
Dead?
Watching preseason Lonzo Ball?
I wasn't sure, but I knew who I wanted to talk to
Someone who actually had fans in that dinky stadium
Mr. Wentz, where did you get all those fans in L.A.?
I don't know.  Philly? North Dakota?
Check the wagon, Suh
It's clean
Just some bibles and the other Kelce
Let's bring him in for questioning
What the
Looks like he eluded the sack
Kid reminds me of a young me
If I ever had passion for the game
Where to now?
It's L.A., there's got to be football fans
Somewhere
I think I've got our next move
I give up